is mihawk stronger than Shanks and is
Whitebeard stronger than Roger power
scaling in one piece is not only
incredibly controversial but also close
to Impossible in other words a lot of
fun which is exactly why today we're
going to rank every single of hundreds
of One Piece characters from the
absolute weakest to the truly strongest
person in all of One Piece well at least
all the characters who at least have a
name and have actually engaged in combat
at some point in the story we're not
exactly gonna try and power skill Makino
or wood slap here or anything but if you
have picked up a weapon to fight with
consider yourself a part of this
ultimate power scaling list starting
with the weakest character in the whole
series Saint Charles now he's not a
fighter so he should have known better
than to shoot hachan and he rightfully
got the color punched right out of him
he's the very first character in our F
tier list but wouldn't it be great if we
could actually quantify the power levels
in one piece as well like it was some
kind of a official system for giving a
number to how strong a character is oh
right well as we learned in the
endoslobby arc the official power
ranking system for one piece that
definitely matters and Oda definitely
didn't just mate up on the spot and then
drop immediately after its first mention
is actually called doriki in other words
starting off with the doriki of one we
got Saint Charles but with him out of
the way we'll now head to the weakest of
the seats the East blue home to notably
weak characters like Luffy Roger and
GARP uh even weaker than these
characters though are the weakest
characters in the entire series The Uso
Pirates I can hear you now really Manu
you're gonna pick on some poor innocent
children playing Pirates which I say
well if the Uso Pirates did want to be
part of this power scaling here they
shouldn't have taken that shovel right
here to Django's unmentionables in doing
so these literal children solidified
themselves as the weakest characters in
one piece and next up is gaimon who does
have some ability with a pistol but is
unable to do much in combat being
completely confined to his treasure
chest and after that is a character most
readers have probably completely
forgotten this Alabaster Bandit who
kidnapped Vivi as a child and was taken
out by another child
ouch then comes the mayor of orange town
that was ready as he was to put on his
armor and protect the town from buggy
unfortunately he was a little bit out of
his League here which does say a lot it
was buggy and next in the mayor tier is
Iceberg oh Iceberg you are a 10 out of
10 mayor but despite having a pistol you
barely had a chance to use it before
being dispatched by zp9 then we also
have hero look he's a doctor not a
fighter and even though he's got plenty
of explosives and Firearms he should
probably stick to Medicine even though
he's not very good at that either on the
other hand the mountain Bandit here that
kidnapped Luffy in chapter 1 is also
incredibly weak despite his high and
mighty attitude regarding his Bounty he
picked a fight with the wrong yonko
slash seeking but after that we actually
already have Zorro's Bounty Hunter
colleagues Johnny and yosaku now their
true power lies not in combat but in
giving us expositions about the seven
Warlords so good job doing that but in
fact those two and everyone else on this
list could be defeated by another
literal child kawina that's because
thanks to kuina swordsmanship training
from her father she would have easily
been able to defeat two bit Bandits and
bounty hunters if we're being honest
however she might not have been able to
beat Isa of the Champions now Isa
doesn't exactly engage in combat in the
series but does have a weapon and is
capable to defend herself moreover she
does demonstrate use of Mantra or
observation hockey which is pretty op
for kids and rounding out the little
girls here though is otama now did she
have an extremely useful devil fruit
power for fighting the Beast Pirates
specifically yes will she be a true
force to be reckoned with once she grows
up to be a kunoichi absolutely but for
now you know she gets to be right here
now back to the east blue though we have
genzo now he couldn't handle arlong but
given his Battle Scars and Prof
efficiency with pistols and the blade
this Sheriff of kokoyashi Village can
handle himself in a normal standard
fight I think kokoro here is next on our
list and she is not much of a fighter
but was plenty strong enough to send
photo Marines flying anyways also an
elderly just like kokoro is the late
nifatari Cobra who didn't have the
strength of his youth when we met him
but as a young man he was easily able to
help igaran here to fight off Bandits
and right around him though is another
Alabaster residence Koza and I think
you've gotta at least be moderately
strong to lead a revolutionary Army but
not as strong as the average line cook a
quick detour back to the baratia brings
us to the baratier chefs right here
sanji's co-workers who are no strangers
to rough housing but do have trouble
holding their own against big name
Pirates and while we're still hanging
around in the East blue how about a
couple of catboys who faced off against
Zorro in Serb Village after then we have
gats here now we didn't see this
gladiatorial announcer in a real fight
but was able to keep rallying the crowd
after getting impaled by Flamingo and
that should count for something in my
book at least Queen odohime here is also
no pushover with her great speed and
Feats of observation hockey after her
we've got some lower ranked but still
named Marines full body and Django wait
didn't they get owned by the beginning
of the series by usop and Sanji yes they
did but they have really gotten their
act together ever since and did some
heavy duty training in the Marines ever
since so we'll bring them up just a
little bit they're so strong now that
they could be right under the weakest of
crocodiles Baroque work members Mr nine
and his baby mama Miss Monday really
bless Oda for the cover stories in the
manga because in what other series would
we learned that these two are married
with a kid now it's a good thing that
they opted for The Quiet family life
because it really weren't cut out for
the whole criminal underground thing if
we're being honest and after that we
have the weakest crewmates of the
weakest of the yonko buggies Entourage
Moji kabaji and alvida now these were
among the first people ever wrecked by
Luffy and the crew in the story so they
get to hang out right here at the bottom
of the list even if they're technically
yonko commanders now I guess and right
after we'll have a character that you
definitely knew had a name bunny Joe aka
the Revolutionary officer that freed
Robin from her cell in Tequila wolf and
just above him we have the officers of
dunk Creek who help with his assault on
baratia Pearl and gin now maybe gin will
climb higher on the list when he finally
will definitely re-enter the story as he
promised but until then here you are
above them we're putting someone who was
a contender for the weakest characters
in the entire series for a while spandom
now he's actually officially confirmed
to have a Dori key score of nine with 10
being the average father Marine strength
oh wait just like Oda actually forgot
about doriki as a concept you better
remember to keep giving these characters
power level so why does such a weak
character beat the others on his list
well toriki doesn't factor in things
like devil fruit powers or special
weapons it only accounts for raw
physical power and spandom has his
special sword Funk freed and in Maya
esteemed opinion the other characters so
far in this list below could probably
not overpower an actual elephant X and
Morgan here though could probably take
down an elephant you know with his
ex-hand now the average Fishman is also
stronger than that being 10 times
stronger than a normal human being so
here we have the crewmates of the arlong
Pirates our friendly takoyaki sales
minhachan and his comrades oh and while
we've met some stronger fishermen than
them later on vendor Deccan the creep
who tried to marry princess Shira Hoshi
can stay on this level as well and just
above them we can actually put Dodd on
and her fellow Mountain bandits from the
Goa Kingdom I think Garb wouldn't have
entrusted his precious grandsons to
someone who couldn't at least take down
some jungler animals but now as we've
moved more solidly into the grand line
we're going to leave the F tier and
slowly enter the D tier with devil
fruits and superhuman strength are a
whole lot more common like Dalton with
his Ox devil fruit who's our first
candidate for the d-tier however without
the straw Hat's help he probably
wouldn't have been able to defeat
Walpole and his Royal Guard so will
place waffle and all the subordinates
that he fused with right here and
Waffle's doriki has to be at least like
I don't know hundreds this is a real
power scaling system that is consistent
and makes sense um I'm not taking
anything else now next we're going to
have our friends from Jaya montblan
cricket and his friends who are for some
reason Apes I mean are these guys minks
or what's what's the deal here anyway
speaking of Mings we're going to put the
non-combatant minks all in this tier
list here most Mings have some degree of
strength and can use Electro punches but
the ones like this nice doctor and this
cute little monkey aren't going to
strike heavy fear into the hearts of
their opponents after these more
low-grade Mings though are the foxy
Pirates not foxy himself will come a
little bit later but all of the various
subordinates that he's won through daily
backfights we will be slotting in right
here and here's the first controversial
take of this video that you've all been
waiting for because right here after
them I'm going to place Captain Kuro and
Don Creek where they beaten by East blue
Luffy yeah but they were also fearsome
pirates in their own right I think we
all just forgot how strong is blue Luffy
actually started out compared to an
average pirate of his sea and also their
Dory key is probably like 200. above
them though are the legions of zombies
from Thriller bark as well as morya
subordinates like Hawk back or Absalom
and following them are the Galileo ship
rides of water 7 as well as the Frankie
family and will actually place the
miscellaneous non-cp9 related people
from Anna's Lobby here too people like
this three-headed judge guy and this
weird noodle man it's a noodle man we're
also going to make an educated guess
here and plays nami's adoptive mom
belmare here as well while she couldn't
overpower arlong she was clearly a
capable fighter and we don't know her
exact rank but she was a marine officer
as we can tell from her jacket here and
around the same level we can toss in
this guy who is sanji's former look
alike and after this level come the
majority of the fighters from skypea I
think like the shandians the cloud army
guy and I think even nl's priests after
that we have another tier of Baroque
works we already talked about Mr nine
but on this level we've got Mr five all
the way up through Mr three galdino and
we can say with a lot of certainty and
not a guess at all that historiki is a
fitting three hundreds and right up here
with him are the heads of alabaster's
Royal Guards igaram Chaka and Pell but
you could make an argument for Pell
being ranked a little bit higher due to
his explosion survival skills also with
him is technically our first straw hat
on the list nefatari Vivi and while
she's clearly not as strong as the other
straw hats so far at least people forgot
that this princess is surprisingly
capable in battle and just above them we
will also put the lowest ranking imple
down jailers such as Domino Josef and
under the wardens and up next is a
character who let's let's be honest
brownbeard is for sure the weakest of
all the Pirates whose name are a color
and a beard I mean Brown beards had to
go somewhere on the list so here he is
and I think you're curious about his
story key it's obviously 400. and since
we all know size isn't all that matters
in one piece up next is the majority of
the tontada military forces now these
dwarves of greenbit are surprisingly
strong for their size individually
they're probably right around lower
donkey shot officers such as the lady
who guarded the smile Factory and Viola
whose power was really more suited to
Observation than combat and right above
them is no hey that can't be right it's
Caribou no not Caribou this is actually
his little brother he's got to be at
least strong enough to make it through
the Grand line to Saba ODI and he has a
real reputation for killing Marine so he
is right up there near the top of the D
tier but finishing off the deer tier
itself is everyone's favorite group of
One Piece villains the new fisherman
Pirates now it's a little bit hard to
place these guys anywhere since they
were just juicing on steroids while they
fought the straw hats but simply the
fact that the Post Time skip straw hats
were still wiping the floor with them
even while they were taking these energy
steroids to me means that these guys
kind of get to round out the d-tier I
feel like that's fairly reasonable and
along with these guys are also the royal
family of Fishman Islands who probably
could have handled the new fisherman
Pirates themselves if it weren't for
those energy steroids but now starting
off with the CTR we have the The
Fearsome female warriors of Amazon Lily
now the Warriors of this island are able
to use Armament hockey and even Infuse
haki into their arrows making Fighters
like Margaret formidable opponents
especially to any non-hockey user also
right here we're going to throw in boa
Hancock's Serpentine sisters and
slightly above the Warriors of Amazon
Lily are pretty much everyone from the
dressrosa Coliseum excluding some
fighters who became captains of the
straw hat Grand Fleet did the tournament
at the Coliseum feature a ton of
Fighters all with unique skills
abilities and levels of strength well
that's what you might think but actually
for the purposes of this video only
being an hour long instead of like 10
hours long everyone from King Riku to
Rolling Logan all have a doraki of
exactly 500 exactly don't argue with me
over this one and more powerful than the
average Colosseum Contender are kaido's
gifters now these smile fruit users make
up the lower ranks of of the Beast
Pirates being stronger than the average
Soldier but far far weaker than any of
the crew's actual Executives all of
these strange human animal hybrid
Pirates like Holden and the infamous
Batman live right here in the bottom of
sea tier and will also throw in old man
hyogoro as well now it's one of Luffy's
old man mentors this guy was probably a
lot stronger when he was younger but
right now he just gets to stay around
here and very similarly ranked at the
lower end of seat here are soldiers of
another yonko crew which is the big mom
Pirates homies like Randolph are right
around the gifter's level as well as the
weaker big mom children such as Lola or
chiffon I mean to be on a yonko crew I
figure you've at least gotta have a Dory
key of 600 and and while we're talking
about lowland chiffon we might as well
include the father of the year pound
here as well there you go and I think
the more mid-tier minks are actually
right above them meteor makes them sound
kind of mid but I mean they're better
than the low tier minks if you get me
now they're not as strong as the
musketeer group here but minks like
blackback or Giovanni are plenty strong
in a fight I think stronger than them
though are some of the vice Admirals
from the Marines now obviously there are
some Vice Admirals who might as well be
Fleet Admiral looking at yugar but some
of them are just a lot lower than
average I think for instance poor one
for our dearly departed T-Bone may he
rest in peace here in seat here and
solidly in the seat here also are some
other people that we got to see in
action at marineford along those Vice
Admirals and that's every single pirate
Captain allied with Whitebeard that's
right all 19 of those captains whose
name and positive you all remember and
so we don't even need to list them all
here because they're all at the same
level and uh two more fishmen also get
to hang out in this tier as well Cody
Jones who at the very least is much
stronger than his crewmates and jimbei's
right-hand man Aladin now one of the
hardest things about about power scaling
in one piece is factoring in the
progression of characters that they have
made during their first appearance in
the series and so while these Baroque
work agents definitely couldn't have
held their own at marineford at their
current strength level that they had
during the alabaster Arc I'm gonna Place
Mr two bonkure Mr Wanda's bones and Miss
Double finger right here I mean by now
their Dory key must be at least 700 and
honestly it would take literal Giants to
take on these powerhouses so here are a
bunch of giants like such as the Marines
giant Squad and speaking of the Marines
let's get some more of them in here as
well mid tiers like this guy with the
terrible chin or the cage lady and this
dude from imple down seems like he's a
good fit for this as well might as well
put him in here as well and let's not
forget about their good friends cp9 no
wait wait a minute does this mean that
we finally get characters with canonical
official doriki levels I've been waiting
for the entire video for this no
guesswork just official Oda confirmed
power levels and first off we have
Khalifa with a donkey of 630 except now
that she's in zp0 it's probably a lot
higher but you can just ignore that
that's for sure 630 still and this round
guy here is 800 with the pink man
following at 810 in our all-time
favorite doorman Bruno at 820. now the
rest of the cipher pole agents will have
to wait for a little bit because their
power level is way higher than that at
least and have they all gotten stronger
since then as well yeah probably but he
didn't come here to do math you came
here to see the strongest characters in
all of One Piece but right around zp9's
power levels are some of the Supernova
super subordinates like pages mathiosos
and the Heart Pirates however claiming
sweet victory over these guys are the
middle tiers of big mom's children
Fighters like Sherlock pudding though as
a yonko child we figure her doriki must
be at least nine hundreds Scotch here
another one of kaido's Fighters is
actually so Mitch that he lost to karibu
on a cover page and as for the final
member of seat here well we're sorry but
Chernobyl you just didn't quite make the
cut here but believe me if this was the
bewitching kunoichi tier list you would
be right on top promise but next we have
arlong and he is honestly one of the
hardest characters to power scale in the
entire series now on the one hand he was
an important member of the sun Pirates
and said to be close in strength to
jimbei himself on the other hand instead
of growing in terms of strength and
power he did hide in the East blue and
evidently let himself go there because
he was defeated by East blue level Luffy
it's really hard to reconcile this
massive disparity in power so we're
going to average out the two extremes
here and place this shark fisherman at
the very bottom of the beat here which
continued right away by the doflamingo
family now disregarding the executives
for now of course however these fighters
from just Rosa gave the straw hats and
an entire country worth of people the
fight of their lives Virgo doflamingo
spy inside the marines has full body
Armament hockey that was strong enough
to shatter sanji's leg Senor pink the
most hard-boiled character in one piece
so far gave Frankie a run for his money
even though Frankie's cybernetic
abilities made him one of the
powerhouses of the straw hat crew and
sugar well sugar was one of the hardest
characters to place on this entire list
I mean is she strong now she's just a
little girl so why isn't she down in the
little girls tier with otama well sugar
doesn't need to be strong because one
touch it all it takes for her to win
nearly any fight instantly this little
girl who's actually really enough a lot
older than she looks has one of the most
overpowered devil fruit abilities in the
entire series one touch allows her to
turn someone into a toy under her
commands and removes all the memories of
them from all other people now arguably
it's recently been hinted at that
sufficient haki could allow you to break
free from an ability like this as we saw
with Trafalgar law when he broke free
from the effects of Doc Q66 fruit
however as we never saw anyone break
free from suga's power through sheer
force of will she does get to be in beat
here at least and actually another
person with a wildly overpowered ability
gets to be right here with sugar as well
and we're talking about perona one of
the warlord gecko moria's commanders on
Thriller bark because Corona's Hollow
fruit gives her the ability to summon
these negative ghosts that completely
drain positivity from her opponents
robbing them off the will to fight or
live and if it weren't for the brilliant
joke by Oda that usob was already
negative and therefore immune to her
powers the straw hats would have been
pretty much decimated by morya really
usab truly was the heart counter to this
ability but it safe to say that perona
could handle her fair share of powerful
opponents and Wow since usop defeated
both perona and sugar Oda really seems
to like having the originally weakest
member of the crew defeat characters who
have the most OP broken abilities in the
story and again we have a bit of a
controversial one here but unfortunately
for usob as arguably one of the weakest
members of the straw hat still gonna
have to place him here in the beat here
but I do believe that you will be ending
up in the a or S tier very soon I mean
usab you've beaten some overpowered
characters but you wouldn't do too well
in most other matchups I think pop
greens are cool and all but let's hope
you get a even bigger power up on l-bath
that will bring you all the way up to
the S tier for now though your Dory key
is precisely one thousand and sadly usop
isn't just the weakest straw hat on this
list we're actually placing him below
all of the other captains of the grand
Fleet yeah I know I know sorry but hey
some of the strongest fighters in the
dressrosa Coliseum swore their
allegiance to Luffy forming the straw
hat Grand Fleet Fighters like the Giant
Warrior hyrujin the number one strawhead
superfan bartolomeo and the pirate
Prince Cavendish they're all in B tier
many of them being fearsome captains in
their own right the average dodike of
this group is at least 1 500. wow now
that we're in beat here the doriki
levels are really going to start to
escalate and right around this level is
another indispensable Ally to Luffy
haribu and love or hate him probably
hate him without this creep's infinite
meat storage Luffy probably would have
ultimately lost to kaido making karibu
kind of sort of a hero of wano as
powerful swamp swamp logia fruit would
probably put him even higher on this
list if it wasn't for his Achilles heel
which is barrels above karibu though are
another batch of characters who
technically have overpowered abilities
but in spite of their potential they're
pretty weak I'm going to call this group
clowns here because inside this group
are two actual clowns buggy and Caesar
now both of these clowns and the clowns
here have crazy devil fruit abilities
that if used properly could make them
truly terrifying but they are not
terrifying unfortunately they're pretty
much just a joke and along with Caesar
Clown we have his fellow scientist Dr
vegapan now with his scientific
knowledge and his devil fruit vegapunk
could easily be considered one of the
top five most powerful characters in all
of One Piece it's just he's not really
interested in combat or fighting as much
as he is in scientific advancements he's
a thinker not a fighter and lumped
together with these silly guys is
another pushover with a fruit much
better than he deserves which is
kuruzomi Orochi who despite his lack of
makeup still exudes very strong big
clown energy and you know who could
probably take all of them out germa 66
and I know that's weird to say that
German 66 is stronger than vegapunk but
this isn't a battle of science it's a
battle of strength so here we are with
Sanji siblings aka the Nazi Power
Rangers and one of the worst fathers in
anime history which if you're a real
anime fan you will know is a true feat
and I would truly like to express my
deepest apologies that judge is not
gonna make it into the top five here and
right above germa we get to the crew
that nearly killed all of them the big
man Pirates minus the heavy hitting
commanders that we'll see again in the
eighth year now here we see the real
power of their combat and shine with
Fighters like Charlotte oven or daifuku
with some truly unique paramecia fruits
this tier of big mom's children can
easily hold their own against
exceptionally strong foes which uh when
you think about it makes it kind of
ludicrous that we're still very solidly
in the beat here I mean these Fighters
have a dorky of precisely 2000 putting
them around the levels of Kaku and Jabra
at the same time of the Lobby art now
this might seem strange but we have to
remember that doriki doesn't factor in
devil fruit abilities just raw power and
we also have to remember that doriki is
not a reliable measure of power levels
so much so that Oda never brought it up
again after I mean no it's very
important we're gonna keep doing it at
the level of these big mom Fighters
though is our second straw hat of the
list which is Nami now this might come
as a bit of a surprise since Nami has
long been thought as part of the
weakling Trio she would rather avoid
fighting altogether especially when
she's up against a powerful enemy
however every time that nami's back is
against the wall and she does get into a
fight she is able to use her
strategically brilliant mind to come out
on top and now that she's received a
power up in the form of big mom's homie
Zeus she should be able to defeat many
of big mom's kids just like she defeated
Heavy Hitters like Miss Double finger or
Khalifa and right here along with nami
we have the final member of the
so-called weakling tree Yo which is Tony
Tony Chopper Now by utilizing his Rumble
ball Transformations the straw head
doctor is able to become strong enough
to trade blows with Queen one of kaido's
strongest subordinates however the
rumble balls that include Chopper's
monster Point have a strict time limit
and result in huge drawbacks when the
transformation ends and due to the side
effects we can't really put him that
much higher than Nami honestly but next
above these two straw hats is a
surprising pick I'd say wiper of the
shandians now now I mean some people
might scoff at me for having a character
from Sky Pia this high on the tier list
but this was a man who was able to kill
God despite NL having been effectively
Untouchable to anyone other than Luffy
wiper was actually able to deal a fatal
blow with his rejectile really if it
hadn't been for an old smart move of
using his electric abilities to restart
his own heart he would have just been
finished here and Pedro and shishilian
are also 2 fearsome Warriors in the beat
here as the leader of the Ming Guardians
and Musketeers respectively they do
outclass most of the other mink Warriors
however right along with them are the
king Birds Servants of both rulers of
zou which include Wanda and the new
leader of the Minx carrots and next
coming in with a exact doriki of 3 000
are the doflamingo family Executives
these three playing card themed leaders
of resrosa don't mess around when it
comes to fighting which is why it takes
a warrior like Kiros to take out any of
them the supernovas would absolutely
wipe the floor with Kiros and the
doflamingo executives though which is
why we're putting the two weakest
members of the worst generation right
here and in my esteemed opinion the two
weakest are the ones who gave up their
dreams to become subservient to kaido
and the Beast pirates in other words
Hawkins and scratchman a poo with their
unique devil fruit abilities they can
harm unsuspecting opponents who are
unaware of how their powers work I mean
Hawkins straw fruit allow allows him to
avoid damage to himself while having it
affect others while a poo can physically
damage people through their sense of
hearing and we're also gonna toss in
jewelry Bonnie around this level at
least until we get another Display of
Power that proves us wrong here x trick
I would argue is a cut above those two
members of the worst generation haven't
made it onto the flying six and with his
powerful allosaur Zone fruit this sword
member was able to infiltrate the upper
echelons of the Beast Pirates and I
would say that the other members of the
flying six are also roughly at this
level we're going to say that they're at
a dirty key off exactly 4 000 which this
time is actually an educated guess
instead of a random number I mean they
were all exact numbers uh 4000 was
Lucy's power level at the time of Anna's
Lobby since who's who one of the flying
six was formerly a member of cp9 we can
take that as a reference and during his
time as a government agent he was
considered to have potential equal to
Rob Lucci so we feel comfortable playing
placing the flying six exactly here at
four thousand roughly at the same level
as Rob Luchi during and his Lobby and
even though he's one of kaido's
All-Stars Jack is also still in this
tier I mean since the members of the
flying six reserve the right to
challenge an All-Star at any time for
the position and who's who was planning
to do just that we figure he can't be
much stronger than the rest of the group
and while we are talking about the
fighters on onigashima we're still
missing one fraction here now our best
guess is that the zp0 agents are also
roughly here in the higher B tier
including newly added zpz agents such as
Kaku and Jabra and that means we're also
assuming that they've grown at least
twice as powerful during the time skip
roughly in line with the straw Hat's
growth as well which would put them at
being around the strength where Luffy
was during the pre-time Skip and I will
place another significant World
Government fighter here as well who is
santol Maru who's the personal guard to
Dr vegapunk and I mean while we're at it
along with the government agents we'll
throw in another group of Marines are I
guess technically the Marines that
should have submitted their resignations
because that's right we're talking about
sword and Fighters like Captain Kobe now
as garb's Prodigy Kobe has been hailed
as the new hero of the Marines and right
in this tier with him we're going to
throw in some non-sword members like
momonga and tashiki Inazuma though could
cut clean through any of these
characters at least that's what we're
guessing I mean as one of the top
fighters of the Revolutionary Army
Fighters like him along with koala Hawk
and the vice captains of the
Revolutionary army they have to be able
to at least go head to head with the
government's top agents I think
momonosuke and his retainers the nine
red scabbers are I guess not quite nine
anymore are next on our list now that
Momo isn't a child anymore and has
better control of his Dragon form he
gets to be all the way up here and while
these Warriors of wano couldn't harm
kaido we shouldn't take their feet
slightly I mean diesel was a division
commander of the white Bay Pirates as
doji made Jack look like a joke and
Nicoma Mushi took out one of big mom's
oldest children pero spero who is also
here in the upper BT here while we're at
it and also for the purpose of this list
conjuro still counts as one of the
scabbards even though he is a dirty
Trader so we'll put all of their power
levels at exactly six thousand and while
we're talking about the citizens of wano
let's add ryuma to the mix as well and I
mean yeah chill we're talking as a
zombie because ryuma was still super
strong so this legendary Samurai gets to
go right here with his descendants along
with Gekko Moria whose Shadow abilities
made him a formidable member of the
shichibukari and it's practically a
thriller Park reunion because we think
that after the time skip Brooks increase
and Powers will put him slightly above
the warlord who once stole his shadow
though when you think about it it's
actually kind of hard to scale broke
since his fight against one of the new
Fishman Pirates is one of the only
one-on-one fights he's ever had a
against a named character though
arguably since he was able to wound one
of big mom's homies we're comfortable
putting him above someone like Moria who
has not exactly been having the best
shows since Thriller Bart then diamond
jozu and flowers Vista two of
whitebeard's commanders are next on the
list now they are very close to the top
of the beat here but don't white have
the same strength as other Top members
of his Fleet this I think is evident
because they were defeated during the
time Skip by our next combatants most of
the Blackbeard Pirates now with their
new devil fruit upgrade some of
Blackbeard's 10 Titanic captains edged
out the competition to stand at the very
top of B tier you wouldn't know it by
looking at them but their average dodiki
is at least eight thousand but now
moving on to the a tier which begins
with yet another member of the straw hat
crew the demon child Nico Robin and we
have now off officially achieved a power
level of over 9 000 after seeing how
Robin's demonio Fleur power-up was able
to absolutely brutalize one of kaido's
top forces now she would probably rather
not spend her time fighting but don't
get on her bad side because she is a
certified a tier one piece character in
The honestly very unlikely case that you
haven't already started typing your very
angry comment of this agreement yet I
mean you probably have but get ready now
because up next is Princess shirahoshi
now yeah yeah she does often live up to
her nickname of wimpy Hoshi but the fact
remains that shirahoshi is literally an
ancient weapon there aren't too many
characters in the series who are easily
going to tussi with someone who has
complete commands over all the sea Kings
capone-based though we feel has enough
fortification and the military strength
to fight your Hoshi I mean his elaborate
strategies during the whole cake Island
show that he's probably not foolish
enough to fight shirahoshi in the middle
of the ocean where the sea Kings live
and with his castle fruit he has great
defensive capabilities not to mention
practically a whole Army inside of him
which sounds so so wrong now tsuru
sengoku and Kong the older Marines are
next on our A-list now yes once upon a
time they were among the strongest of
the Marines forces probably in the top
20 or so earning them a well-deserved
retirement now admittedly Kong himself
is really just a guest since we've yet
to see him in action but sengoku's
powerful Golden Buddha fruit and turo's
legendary exploits see them a high spot
on the list of one piece's strongest
characters Kong isn't technically part
of the Legendary Marine Trio along with
Zulu and zengoku that would be a certain
Monkey D garpa spoiler alert it'll be a
little bit later on this list but before
that I would argue that these old
retirees can't quite keep up with some
of one piece's end game Fighters the
commanders of the Revolutionary Army are
crazy strong enough so that they can
even put up a fight against absurdly
powerful characters like the Marine
Admirals we figured out to go Toe to Toe
with an admiral your power level has to
be at least 12 000 and that's why the
five commanders of the Revolutionary
armies will be right here in the a tier
but wait aren't there only four
revolutionary Army commanders though
karasu Marley Lindbergh and Bello Betty
right each having command over one of
the four blues well don't forget about
the commander over the grand line
Emporio ivankov and as they would say
hee haw but moving on Frankie is one of
the stronger members of the straw hats
ever since the time skip Oda has loved
showcasing his fighting ability even
while some crewmates have hardly even
gotten a proper one-on-one fight but
especially factoring in awesome
power-ups like the Frankie Shogun his
technological Weaponry can't be denied
did I technically just imply that that
means that Frankie can put up a fight
against the Marine Admiral yeah could
Oda immediately decide to make this
opinion look terrible in retrospect also
yes but I mean we're talking about the
man who ran over big mom's face with a
motorcycle now that is super and worth a
doriki of 15
000. I'd say that Boa Hancock could
probably easily dispose of Frankie
considering that he and most of the
characters in the series would be turned
to stone five seconds into the fight but
even for people who can resist her devil
fruit Powers using their Mastery of
hockey or their apathy towards beautiful
women let's not discount her powerful
Armament and conquerors hockey like she
said after the Marines decided to hunt
down the former Warlords the shichibukai
earned their spots because they are very
very strong and that's why right above
Boa Hancock we have yet another form of
warlord crocodile and this is most
definitely going to be the most
controversial placement on this entire
list so far because in the same way that
it didn't make any sense for East blue
Luffy to be able to defeat arlong a
former member of the senpai whether it's
a pre-gear Luffy somehow managed to take
out sir crocodile now two Crooks credit
let's not forget that he also nearly
killed Luffy twice and would have
succeeded if it weren't for that
Madeleine Robin and since crocodile is
now in the good company of dracul mihog
in the cross Guild we can only guess
that he's gotten a lot stronger since
the time skip placing him in the eighth
year with a doriki of at least 16
000. and just
etching him out of the way is smoker
another very controversial pick I know
now this vice admiral of the Marines
hasn't exactly had the best showing
after the time skip getting bodied by
Virgo and doflamingo but hey so did
Sanji and nobody is going to argue that
he should be lower on this list right
right and smoker is the kind of
character to take his defeats very
seriously and much like the straw hats
seek to get stronger you can only guess
that smoker will have a role to play
during the end of the story and at that
point he'll most likely be able to fight
on par with the top tiers I think and
you can't say anything because this is
my video now The Mad Monk rosh is a
supernova who hasn't gotten that much
Spotlight so far but we do know that
this guy Islander was able to defeat one
of big mom's sweet commanders and his
devil fruit that allows him to absorb
kinetic energy and turn it into raw
strength which really is no joke Don
Quixote Flamingo is one of the strongest
of the seven War it literally took gear
for Luffy to even stand chance against
him but let's also not forget the day
that though Flamingo had been having
before that fight he's been gamma knifed
and had to use his fruit to stitch his
own organs together he had utterly
defeated law he had been maintaining a
string clone for who knows how long and
on top of it he had activated The
Birdcage an attack so powerful that
somehow even Master Swordsmen like Zorro
kinemon or fujitora somehow couldn't cut
through it and on top of that he used
his devil fruit Awakening to fight Luffy
till the very end I have a feeling that
a peak condition though Flamingo would
have been able to put up an even more
intense fight against gear 4. and so
very close to the flamingo we have three
of the sweet commanders smoothie cracker
and the ever mysterious snack now
technically a Rouge did defeat snack but
since we've never actually seen this
character we're still just gonna throw
him in with the others cracker though
we've seen in prolonged battle with
Luffy and while doflamingo struggled
against gear 4's immense speed and
strength kraka was able to keep up just
with his army of biscuit soldiers but
even stronger than these three is
another yonko commander and the most
funky one as well Queen now Queen
already comes packed with the power of
an ancient Zone type devil fruit that
grants him the raw strength of a
Brachiosaurus however it's of course his
scientific knowledge and cybernetic
enhancements that make Queen the plague
a real Force to behold Queen was able to
Grant himself the individual powers of
each of the germa 66 members in an
effort to show his superiority over
sanji's father Vin smoke judged sadly
did not make it into the top five of
this video and with Queen also comes
King kaido's right-hand man and as the
last known lunarian King has Incredible
strength and endurance enough to bring
Zorro within an inch of his life and on
top of his lunarian abilities his
paternathon devil fruit gives an even
greater strength as well as the ability
of flight and so as one of the strongest
yonko commanders out there King's doriki
comes in at 18 000 and I really wish I
wouldn't have to say paternathon anymore
I really don't like saying dinosaur
names in English now above King though
come two more yonko commanders shidiu
and Jesus Burgess as the two of the
strongest members of the black Bay
Pirates these guys will be some of the
straw Hat's final enemies city of the
rain's reputation precedes him when we
first meet him in imple down this
sadistic former Jailer is a supremely
strong swordsman and on top of that he
has the ability to turn invisible now
and with his new strong strong fruit
Jesus Burgess is going to be able to
master some incredible Feats off
strength and around Studio's level of
strength as well is his old comrades the
former Chief Warden of imple down
Magellan now during the imple down Arc
Magellan was an Unstoppable force of
nature because his Venom basically
incapacitated nearly everyone it touched
if it hadn't been for the inmate's
teamwork and Mr two's Noble sacrifice
Magellan might have single-handedly
stopped the escapees including Luffy and
Blackbeard meant with a power like that
his dorky breaks the 22 000 point mark
but now we go from a warden of imple
down to someone who was recently sent to
prison Edward Weevil now the idea that
Weevil is in fact the real biological
son of Whitebeard is suspect to say the
least but if he does have strength to
rival the world's strongest men then
clearly Vivo is absurdly strong more
clues for this are the fact that his
Bounty before becoming a warlord was the
highest of any of the warlord's previous
bounties not that bounties are power
levels I mean we have dodiki for that
which is way more accurate and portas
the ace is up next as the second
division Commander for Whitebeard the
former wielder of the fire fruit is
quite formidable although we have seen
him suffer some defeat in the series one
of them quite fatal but only at the
hands of true top tier characters like
Akainu and Blackbeard and if it takes
that sort of caliber of a character to
topple Ace then he truly is one of the
series strongest not quite as strong I'd
say though as another flame wielder the
straw hat Chef Sanji and as a member of
the monster Trio Sanji is one of the
straw Hat's most reliable and Powerful
Fighters now that he's awakened his
latest Vin smoke abilities for Wally
increased speed and durability he is
solidly in the yonko commander level and
if I had to guess which I don't have to
sanji's doriki is nothing less than 25
000. and just ever so slightly beating
Sanji with a power level of 25
000 and one is jimbei the Knight of the
sea and helmsmen of the straw hats and
honestly it's amazing they've ever made
it so far with someone who actually
knows how to steer a ship now at this
point in the series we'll say that
jimbei is slightly stronger than Sanji
because I mean just look at this man of
a Fishman he's the former captain of the
sun Pirates and a former warlord and his
reputation isn't just all talk either
jimbei is strong and fearless enough to
face down a yonko like big mom without a
moment's hesitation with a feeling that
by the end of the series Sanji will
reclaim his place as the third strongest
straw hat but for now we're gonna have
to give it to jimbe here an even
stronger than jimbei are some characters
that we met very early on in one piece
Dory and bragi the captains of the giant
Pirates now these two friends of shang's
fought one another for nearly a century
on little garden likely training and
becoming stronger throughout all that
time we know this because at the end of
the arc they absolutely obliterated this
massive Island sized goldfish with the
same attack that big mom and kaido use
together as well and they recently used
the same technique to obliterate kids
and his ship but wait there's more the
one piece world is host to even bigger
and stronger Giants than Dorian froggy
the ancient Oni race like the legendary
Warrior Oris and his ancestor little
ores Jr that's because even in ors's
zombified state it took a team effort
between all of the straw hats and
stuffing Luffy full with a ridiculous
amount of powerful Shadows to create
nightmare Luffy for them to even stand a
chance though as they say size isn't
everything also in one piece so next we
have the chief of staff of the
Revolutionary Army the flame Emperor
Sabo who has an estimated Dory key of
thirty thousand now when he obtained the
powers of Ace's flamethrowed he was
already a proven Warrior having been
brought up by Dragon however with his
brother's fire abilities now he was able
to easily fight on par with Marine
Admirals and completely washed Jesus
Burgess one of Blackbeard's top fighters
though to our knowledge that was before
he actually had a devil fruit of his own
and then of course we have the red hair
Pirates Who possibly are the strongest
crew in the entire Series right now now
we don't have a ton of Feats of any of
these characters so we're going to
mostly go on reputation here but up next
are the prominent members of shanks's
crew such as yasop and lucky Roo and
since lucky Roo for some reason is
supposedly the fastest character of the
series he clearly belongs in the upper
ranks of the a tier and just slightly
above them we have the old crew members
of shanks's former Captain characters
like Rayleigh and scopper Gabon really
in his prime would obviously be higher
on this list but according to the man
himself in his old age he probably
wouldn't be quite able to fight against
characters like Blackbeard however as
members of the Roger Pirates these
characters are among the strongest in
the entire verse still at their current
age and Rob Luchi is next with a Dory
key of 40 000. now we're going to say
that with his new devil fruit Awakening
he's 10 times stronger than he was at in
his Lobby which isn't too crazy
considering this agent of zp0 is able to
withstand the awesome powers of gear 5
Luffy honestly of course the fight in
Anna's Lobby against Luffy remains one
of the best in all of One Piece pushing
Luffy to his absolute limits and now
this rival of Luffy has kept pace
somehow becoming one of the strongest
assets to the world governments however
he's not quite as strong as Stussy who
was able to immobilize both Luchi and
Kaku nearly instantaneously now you can
make the argument that they were both
caught off guard by her betrayal but
Luchi isn't exactly the type of
character to put his trust into anyone
and with his observation haki he should
have been able to at least defend
himself but he was rendered completely
unconscious with a single bite up next
are the most powerful children of kaido
and Big Mama respectively Yamato and
katakuri now they have both inherited a
big portion of their parent strength our
guess is that their dodiki must be
exactly 50 000 each during the wano art
Yamato was actually able to hold off her
father while Luffy was recovering and
thanks for mythical dog food Yamato has
increased strength and ice powers that
make her a top-tier fighter being able
to fight kaido one on one which is a
real feed reserved for truly only the
strongest characters katakuri on the
other hand gave Luffy one of his hardest
fights in the series one that in a way
Luffy didn't even technically win really
it was more of a tie and in the end
katakuri just lets him leave without
continuing the fight and ultimately
Luffy earns katakuri's respect even more
than he truly defeated him in combat so
with his incredible future sight
observation hockey and complete Mastery
of his special paramecium fruit katakuri
is one of the strongest yonko commanders
out there but speaking of observation
hockey Mastery though it's quite a fee
to see into the future but it is also a
feat to be able to be aware of all the
happenings of an entire Island in other
words enter NL our boy an enemy that
Luffy was only able to defeat due to the
luckiest devil fruit matchup ever also
this ammo arguably have some type of
future sight or was his prediction about
how only five people would be left in
the battle after three hours this was
just a really lucky guess I mean granted
we've never seen NL fight any fellow
logo users but given that he had a great
Mastery of observation hockey before we
even knew what that was it's very likely
that he has picked up other types as
well our guess is that someone who
claims the position of a God is a shoe
in for conquerors hockey at the very
least but up next quickly approaching
the top of the eighthier are used as kid
and killer and they haven't exactly had
the best time in recent memory being
instantly obliterated by one of the
strongest characters in the entire
series but let's not forget that these
two were present for roof piece these
two members of the first generation were
able to engage in combat against big mom
and kaido and kit even helped to bring
down big mom along with the next person
on our list which is of course Trafalgar
law of the heart Pirates now the opioid
me is fittingly one of the most OP
fruits in the entire series some might
question his position here since he was
defeated by doflamingo but since he's
awakened his devil fruit and has even
been strong enough to take out big mom
with kids help of course he is not the
most physically powerful character but
using his strategic Brilliance in
coordination with his broken devil fruit
makes him a more than deadly fighter
after all it's easy to beat people when
you can just remove their heart but just
above law though and at the Pinnacle of
the a-tier is the right-hand man of the
World's Strongest Man Marco the Phoenix
with a doriti of 60 000. I personally
think that this pineapple-shaped man is
in another league as a yonko commander
being able to fight king and queen
kaido's top two subordinates
simultaneously at in his restorative
devil fruit abilities and you're dealing
with a seriously strong mythical Zone
user which now drum roll please for the
first member of the S tier golden is
roronoa Zorro the future strongest
swordsman of the world and the right
hand of the future pirate king and as
the very first swordsman since Odin who
was actually able to cut kaido Zorro is
solidly in yonko Commander level and is
rapidly approaching yonko level himself
as we're being honest if he's not
already there and as the story barrels
towards his inevitable fight with mihawk
we only see him climbing the ranks of
this list even faster however there is
one more yonko commander on this list
which is of course the first Maid of the
red hat Pirates Ben Beckman in other
words the man that kizaru took one look
at and said no not today despite having
no problem scrapping with Rayleigh on
Saba Odie archipelago also I know that's
not literally what kisado said and it
was more surprise or Intrigue than fear
but just let me cook please okay after
him we've got Bartholomew Kuma now I
feel like Kuma gets left out of a lot of
power scaling discussions but this is a
man who has never not once taken an L
unless you count the complete removal of
his personality and Free Will as an L
but we don't his papa fruit is another
one of the most broken fruits of the
series allowing him to teleport his
opponents anywhere in the entire world
and even expelling intangible Concepts
like pain and memories in other words I
have no doubt that this cyborg could
hold his own against some of the
strongest characters in the story though
I'd say he'd have less of a great time
against the Marine Admirals yokugyu
fujitora and kizaru and for good measure
we're including aokiji here as well they
all have insanely powerful devil fruits
and complete Mastery over them they
command Elemental forces of nature
they're the greatest powers of the world
government and the Marines and don't
sleep on these absolute units because
after all their average toriki is at
least 75
000 and after the Admirals you know it's
only going to be crazy names from here
on out and next is the Giga chat himself
kozuki Odin a member of Rogers and
whitebeard's crew and the former Shogun
of wano now this man was able to fight
on the same level as kaido and if it
hadn't been for the trickery of the
kurozumi clan he likely actually would
have defeated the emperor of the sea
however slightly above taking the W was
kaido and along with him his fellow
former rocks crewmate Charlotte Lin Lin
big mom herself now most Fighters even
with proficient Armament hockey can't
even lay a scratch on either big mom or
kaido in fact it takes Elite level
techniques like advanced conquerors
hockey or awaken devil fruit abilities
to even stand a slight chance against
any of these yonko but as if that wasn't
enough on top of this big mom and kaido
both have absolutely insane devil fruit
abilities and honestly between big mom's
homies and the ability to rip the
literal soul from anyone who fears her
and kaido's giant dragon form and
Mastery of flame clouds powers are said
like they're nearly unlimited if we're
being honest but let's not forget about
big moms in kaido's former crewmate of
the Rocks Pirates which is Shiki the
Golden Lion now let's not forget that
the Strong World movie is not canon so
we can't consider his defeat at Luffy's
hands as Sirius however we can look at
his legendary status as a rival of Roger
himself in his day this user of the
float float fruit was one of the
strongest pirates in the world and it
took both GARP and sengoku to take him
down and similarly at yonko level I
plays the legendary hero of the Marines
himself monkey D GARP I mean in his
prime GARP would regularly fight against
yonko level people like Roger Whitebeard
but even now in his old age he can
unleash devastating techniques like this
punch right here and he may just be a
vice admiral but let's not forget that
he has repeatedly turned down promotion
in favor of maintaining his own freedom
from working directly under the
celestial dragons and he was likely the
strongest Marine in his day and
continues to be among the strongest
characters in the story even in his
retirement and now it is time for the
top 10 most powerful characters in one
piece the strongest of the strong
because from here on out every single
character just reaches absolutely
ludicrous levels of combat power and at
number 10 with a crazy dirty key of 100
000 is sadazuki better known as the
fleet Admiral akinu and uh checking my
notes I see here that his Feats include
the removal of kuzans like as the
removal of whitebeard's face enter the
removal of Ace's life sorry I had to and
uh he's hotter than fire magma fruit is
one of the most destructive abilities
that we've seen in the entire Series in
fact to be more destructive than the
magma fruit which you probably need like
two devil fruits so here at number nine
we have Marshall D teach Luffy's
greatest rival for the position of
pirate king and we do know that
Blackbeard has some some downsides to
his power he feels pain more strongly
than other characters thanks to his
Darkness fruit we've seen him back down
from several opponents refusing to fight
characters like Shanks or Rayleigh and
opting for a more strategic approach but
still with his Darkness fruit and the
earthquake fruit he can nullify other
fruit users abilities as well as having
the power potentially strong enough to
break the planet itself and don't
underestimate the power of his secret
third devil fruit the off-screen
off-screen know me which he uses to
decimate Ace law and to steal
whitebeard's devil fruit unseen by all
which brings us to the eighth strongest
character in all of One Piece which is
currently its protagonist Monkey D Luffy
with a power level of 120
000. yep above Blackbeard and akinu
well we expect the future pirate king to
climb all the way to the very top of
this at the end of the series of course
but for now let's put him at eight his
immense willpower has allows him to
master all three types of hockey to an
advanced level at in his mythical Zone
devil fruit the Nika fruit and he has
the ability to do practically anything
his Limitless imagination can think up
he has come a very long way from the
East blue and now after defeating kaido
he's truly deserving of the yonko title
but slightly above him adds number seven
we go to Luffy's father Monkey D Dragon
that's the leader of the Revolutionary
Army and based on his family tree we can
assume that he is very strong however we
have yet to actually see him using any
of his powers within the actual story so
for now his placement is just based on
Vibes and context but I honestly I mean
I think we'd all be shocked if he isn't
one of the strongest characters in one
piece and so number six instead goes to
Dracula mihawk as the strongest
swordsman in the world mihawk is the
ultimate Benchmark that Zorro hopes to
catch one day and and since mihawk used
to hold regular duels with the likes of
Shanks we can reasonably assume that
despite his status as a former warlord
he is much closer to yonko level in
reality and as the cross Guild makes
their move towards the one piece we're
excited to see what events will bring
him and Zoro together in the end for the
cataclysmic battle that we are all
waiting for forever but even mihawk
wouldn't have a chance for what is up
next because now it is finally time for
the top 5 strongest characters we'll
call it like s plus plus plus tier or
whatever where the duty is just really
off the charts and for these last 5
characters we really don't want to set
the internet Ablaze so the five
strongest characters are really whoever
you want them to be okay fine just
kidding we'll rank them but hey just
keep in mind the power scaling stuff
it's really hard especially for a series
with powers as crazy as one piece for
example most series would have the
World's Strongest Man as both of the
world's strongest man and but not not
this one Edward Newgate AKA Whitebeard
is number five with a doriki of 150
000. now during the Paramount War
Whitebeard showed no fear in facing down
the full forces of the Marines he's
powerful enough to strike fear Into the
Heart of someone like Akainu all while
having endless compassion for his crew
who he considered his family as the
original owner of the Quake Quake fruit
he had the strength to make the world
itself tremble to cause tidal waves and
Scatter the ground itself as well as his
opponent's bones and faces I guess but
above him at number four I'm going to
place another yonko in the same league
as Whitebeard Shanks now he was the man
who originally inspired Luffy to set
sail and he was a cabin boy on none
other than Roger's ship he is one of the
world's most tearsome pirates but also
is all but confirmed to be a descendant
from the celestial dragons themselves he
was able to One-Shot use this kit
despite kid working together with law to
bring down big mom Shanks even has
conquerors haki so powerful that he
knocked an admiral aramaki out of his
Forest form and caused the Marine
Admiral to retreat from wano even though
Shanks himself was mild off the coast
really shangs is at the Pinnacle of
power today so for number three we have
to actually go to the past and dig out
an old person who's already dead the
former pirate king Goldie Roger he was a
man who single-handedly launched a great
pirate era and the captain of the only
crew to ever reach the end of the grand
line we're going to place his power
level at 200 000. I mean his prime
before his execution he was a friend and
rival to Garb the hero of the Marines
and could easily fight Toe to Toe with
insanely strong characters like
Whitebeard his shadow is cast over the
entire series and for very good reason
because he is the one who achieved the
most in the world of pirate accuracy and
yet number two goes to another great
pirate of Rogers era Rox D zabek now we
still don't know much about rocks but we
have big clues that his power was out of
this world for starters he had three
future yonko working under him as part
of his crew Whitebeard big mom and kaido
were all part of the Rocks pirates in
addition to other significant ones like
Shiki and moreover in order to stop
rocks at the god Valley incident GARP
and Roger had to actually team up this
could imply that if neither of them
could beat him alone that it required
Two fighters of Roger and garb's level
to contend with rocks meaning that he's
likely stronger than either of them but
finally we have the most powerful
character in the world at number one
with a dirty key of 250
000 which my experts by the way tell me
that is the maximum level of doriki is
imsama the secret ruler of the world's
governments ooh controversial now not
only does emo appear to wield some sort
of insane transformation ability but on
top of that they wield more power than
any other individual in the one piece
World they control the entire world
government which has the entire planet
firmly clutched in its grasp on top of
that crazy Beast Forum imsama can also
easily wipe out entire islands with a
single wave of their finger using what
we presume to be a copy of the ancient
weapon Uranus made by DR vegapunk and
you probably don't remember that we
might have actually seen this insane
weapon all the way back during the time
skip in this mysterious panel with
Capone beige as his ship gets sucked up
into the sky and if you want to learn
100 more secrets in one piece that you
probably missed you can watch that video
right here thanks for watching the most
uncontroversial video I've ever made on
this channel